Christelle was pushing her
three-year-old son in a buggy in North
London when she became victim of what is
a growing problem a seemingly motiveless
stabbing by a young teenager he said
give me your phone and I said no and
then he just reached around to the back
of my leg my left thigh and just stabbed
me in the back of it so so quick didn't
see it coming didn't see a knife didn't
see anything it was just complete I was
completely stunned I've done first day
training I work in a nursery so I've
always sort of left there thinking I
haven't learnt anything I don't well I
ever remember this and they've always
assured me that you know it comes back
to you and it was you know I was like
right I've been been stabbed I had no
idea how bad it was buyers knew
straightaway pressure you know I don't
want to bleed out here you know in front
of my son yeah so he looked like a kid
like a kid did he steal anything no no
what do you think the motivation was it
just didn't feel like a robbery
it felt you know it felt to me like the
goal was to stab me why I don't know
you know gang initiation you hear a lot
about that last month Sky News reported
on gangs and singing about twins calling
City is for stabbing and there have been
reports of young people committing knife
attacks as an initiation process often
stabbing victims in the upper leg the
individual story of a mother with her
child being stabbed on a residential
street like this for no apparent reason
by a child does sound shocking but it's
becoming ever more common 41% of
stabbings in London were conducted by 15
year olds to 19 year olds and 8% by 10
year olds to 14 year olds so that's
around half of all knife crime offences
committed by people who are either
teenagers or younger still it happened
in broad daylight and could easily have
been fatal Crystal's husband says his
wife's attacker needs to think of the
consequences and society needs to wake
up to the problem socially we've become
completely desensitized to it completely
assuming it is just going on gang
violence
and if anything comes out of this whole
process it's not it's not it's happening
everywhere its crisis is a crisis it
needs to be addressed as a crisis what's
your what's your message to those young
people just what you know isn't a bad
choice you know I'm you know you've made
me feel anxious about leaving my own
home I'm from this area I grew up here
have never felt anxious in Islington
ever so you know just a bad choice
suspect is described as a black male 5
foot 3 aged 14 to 16 there have been no
arrests so far
Jason Farrell Sky News